the first speaker in our last session
today is circa motivational who was who
is from the University of Illinois
urbana-champaign he also was my advisor
and this session title is related topics
which everybody knows that is the last
day last session called related topics
means unrelated topics I mean yeah so
this was my title and I thought that's
really related no Chinese restaurant
process big data learning a little too
related and I had to watch out for the
organizers put me on the last session
called related topics means unrelated so
really so I watch out for the organizers
and say that we'll do something
unrelated it's an anonymous messaging
and so the two parts messaging and
anonymous and messaging is how the world
works and if you missed the boat
Facebook dead and it cost them 16
billion to buy wats app and everything
works on messaging and then there is
slackware three places office email and
that's also messaging and each one of
these is in things even the bottom one
is definitely a value over a billion
right and if messaging is how people
communicate and there is not necessarily
hope and that's the messaging part and
anonymity is something else where some
people want to say something and it's
pretty sensitive and important people
still want to say sensitive things but
maybe you know not quite quite as since
quite as important and so there are
messaging apps you would imagine that
cater to anonymous communication so we
are non-limiting there are two kinds of
anonymity there is data unanimity and
metadata unanimity that means data as in
what is the content is content to secret
or not that's not what I'm talking about
i'm looking at metadata that means in
particular the source of who is talking
the content itself you would like to
make it as public as possible but the
source is what we want to hide so there
are messaging apps and particular if you
have any middle school college going
kids you have heard of UK
definitely phones have you care
candidates I mean nothing else catches
attention as banning a nap in every high
school one block of every high school in
the country so that definitely catches
people's attention so there are these
apps and they basically what they do is
so you can build their geography based
and do you get messages from people in
that geography and you just don't know
who it is from it's anonymous so secret
is a slightly different so somebody was
trying to come and this is messages said
till annoy so we we get dkx oh alright
so secret is another messaging app
primarily used in the valley here so
people are cutting but it's more
socially filtered so this done in this e
cakk was not really filtered you get all
kinds of messages and secret is mostly
socially filtered so you get messages
from your friends you just don't know
which one of your contacts and so all
right but the thing with all these
messaging apps is that they are not
really anonymous there is a central
authority that maintains everything and
and the you just have to ask them and
not even necessarily politely and it's
not anonymous and so there's plenty of
these kind of things and it's there even
under federal wire type law so they are
actually stored all the messages are
stored and they're not anonymous at all
and I want to think of anonymity at
level of an adversarial scale which is
authoritarian so strong adversaries we
should be able to handle them and then
centralized networks are definitely not
the way to think about them so there are
anonymous communication itself has been
around and the primitives exist The
Onion Router is a popular one but
they're primarily built for
point-to-point so you want to do from
one place to another place get to make
an IP link and go through a bunch of
roads and the onion wrote is a pretty
good one but yeah and we would like to
do messaging so that's really the point
of the stock and if you want to make it
really unrelated I could talk about the
app we have it is called wildfire and we
could all download and play with it by
that may just mean I'm happy to do that
maybe offline okay so let's for this
talk will keep it more so it has several
interesting things first of all we will
be able to do because it is a
distributed setting we can do
lightweight crypto methods and one can
provide strong at will guarantees
against authoritarian adversaries and
you can also play with messaging and
it's something that you can download on
your phone and play but just for this
talk will just do what you know it's an
information theory session so we'll do
some likelihoods and probability of
detection and some learning so we'll
skip this actual app so the point is
distributed messaging and that's what I
want to do so in other words I don't I
want to get away from centralized
there's no central server maintaining
logs and tracks every one person would
know who their friends are maybe they're
in this context I'm not so worried about
the actual physical layer so I may be
wired Wireless and thinking it's an
internet so if friends are just IP
addresses and have a list of them and I
would like to communicate with them and
I have a message I send it and they like
it they hit the like button they it goes
to their friends and so forth so what
can an adversary do well first an
adversary can maybe learn who got the
message who are the rumor this is not
very coarse-grained maybe it has some
side information on figuring out who got
it when the other one is they could also
potentially some of the users themselves
could be Spice so they can collude and
when the users themselves are spies they
are private to more information than
just who got the message they'll not
only they know they got it they also
know metadata like the exactly when they
got it and if that message came with
some headers control information they
know that too and so spice comes with
these things and really you have timing
some nodes are commuting and maybe you
know who has what so there's a little
bit less course not as detailed timing
but maybe you can get right information
that way and all about distributed
network 4 and 6 is is to figure out the
author so there's a long list of work in
this area recent I mean this is a
fast-moving space messaging apps or
don't even really exist a few years ago
and this is very fast and the
corresponding
network forensics are also new in
distributed settings and the traditional
method is this thing called so you won
first you want to think of a social
network as a graph and throughout this
talk I'll think that the adversary knows
the graph okay so it's not and I want to
give the adversity as many privileges as
possible so I want to work with
authoritarian adversaries so you want to
think of how does how does information
flow we typically you send it and an
author sends it to some is someone or if
its friends and depending on when they
watch it they may hit like and then you
get to set their friends and so forth
this is usually how social networks work
Twitter works this way and it if one
standard model is this thing called the
diffusion model it's been around it's
how messages spread on graphs and gossip
algorithms so this been known at least
this community we know how messages go
on graph with it is with this random
spreading model and what do you do with
this let's say if you look at this
adversary which is sort of course it
knows exactly who got the message but
doesn't quite nail down it's not any one
of these nodes so it doesn't have this
timing information what can you do well
can I how does it find the message
source the point is it just tries to put
a ball and try to find the center of
this of this graph you can eyeball
things and say ha that's the center and
that's probably the source I mean we
have to define what center means and
there are different variants and this
thing called the Jordan Center we just
looks at the longest distance to from
one node you pick a node and the Jordan
Center Jordan centrality or the
eccentricity of the node is how far each
no dissenting the largest one you can
look at distant centrality which sums of
the distances and rumors and tell it is
a little bit different in the sense that
it weights differently for degrees the
degrees maybe not homogeneous in any
case the point is if you just have
diffusion one of these centrality is
really works you can it's a inference
problem you can do the maximum
likelihood you can try to do the
likelihoods of each source being the
measure of author given this particular
realization of the graph and here I'm
plotting the likelihood in a color-coded
wear dark colors means high likelihood
light means low likelihood and you'll
see that the central nodes are the ones
that are more likely and
the men so basically random spreading
just you can be anonymised even though
it's distributed the fact is the
likelihoods concentrate and around the
source and then you can catch him and
this not our research this was
popularized by they will shine talk it's
a man in a 2011 paper and there are
several works following up on this
theorems are not as many to come with
but practical experiments are quite
conclusive even if you don't find
exactly the source within one-half
you'll find it something like this so
diffusion is not enough you can just
distribute it is not enough in other
words that's what i want to say oh this
one is this adversary here the adversary
just knows the underlying graph
throughout and here it knows which of
the nodes got infected sometimes
adversary may also know when which not
got infected well if the adverse it
knows everything that means not all the
nodes is not infected and has timing
information or all of them then it can
just sort and in some sense that's a
success because if you can get an
authoritarian adversity like NSA to
snoop on everybody's fun then you won
the game I mean it's to the extent that
you lost it you won it no that's the
point I mean you don't want to make it
hard for them to snoop put enough
barriers so in this one there is no
timing and they can do it so how do you
do with time in let's say you may not
know all the dots so no no some of the
notes and again I'm using the color here
dark colors means let's say the message
was earlier light colors means it got
later and now you don't really want to
do the center because somehow the darker
colors are where near the darker colors
are where the source probably originally
started and so you want to somehow wait
the distance information the distance
and Nationality notions by timing and
again there is a long line of work where
I mean practice fight and percent of
note you don't need to know all of them
fightin percent with timing helps you d
anonymize their early work of pinto
Patrick Keenan and Martin literally in
the physics review letters and several
works later and not follow I'm just
referring to the early work in this area
point again is that if you follow
diffusion model wait timing without
timing you really get to the anonymou
the catch is our goal is really the
opposite I don't want to actually find
in fact I want to make this job hard and
I'm fine actually I'm I take both sides
that's why it's a spy vs spy which is
for a given model will try to find the
best possible adverse real attack and
voiceover some and we'll try to do the
best on both sides and without time
angoor with time against David just
having information because if you have
time information for every note then you
know the first guy must be the roof
right and that's a win actually because
that means adversary got so much putting
so much effort to learn everybody's
timing in some sense it's a win that's
really the final goal of this project is
that you put so much burden on the
adverse yaw thority an adversary that
they really have to subpoena every
single person at that level you really
are out coming out of luck and it's a
wind actually I think if you get to that
stage so we want to put enough burden
that miata at Versailles authoritarian
but not that authoritarian luckily they
can swim sniffling sand yeah not getting
to everybody's phone yet and if they do
then I agree that's it actually there is
nothing else one can do in some sense
the goal used to get towards that to
make it hard enough so I want to
engineer the spread of the spread to
hide authorship to make it as hard as
possible to find and they're interesting
problems on their own without timing and
with timing and I think both are
interesting and turns out this one
solution for both and that's what I'll
talk about and that's this so point I
guess is that if you do de fuchsia and
it just doesn't work so let's try with
lines this is a simplest kind of a graph
just too so the next 5-10 minutes are
just play I only have five minutes no
okay so 10 minutes good so I spend a few
minutes just playing around with some
simple graph so that way we get an idea
of where we are coming it where it's
going and then I try to put together a
system around it so if you do a line
that's the simplest graph possible the
red one is the source node and you start
going on both sides independently then
you basically you try to find the author
you try to do the likelihoods there's
clear concentration around the center I
mean it's not terribly concentrated
the sense that it's a line so you still
have some hiding but you have this
Gaussian type central limit theorem and
so you're the more to the middle is
probably very likely the most likely one
and there's still some hiding but the
probability of detection is at least
there's some hiding so it's 1 over root
n so on a line you get some but I want
to do better I want to do 1 over N I
want to hide everybody so even an edge
one could just as well have been likely
as the other edge or the center that's
what I really want to do mine diffusion
doesn't get there diffusion makes this
concentration happen and on three is
it's even worse so we will see that so
how do you do this so and that's sort of
the first that's how we started the
slides with it's a Chinese restaurant
process with only two tables and then I
discovered it's also called the pole yes
own process where are there only two
balls in the Sun one red and one blue
and with probability half you pull one
ball out so I describe how the sample
path works and let's say the red comes
out and now you put it back so it's kind
of the opposite of sampling without
replacement here your sample with double
replacement you put two back for
everyone get out you put that back and
you put one new one of the same color
and now you realize that there are two
red and one blue and write this more
likely again because now the steward of
three you get it out and you put one
again and now it suddenly becomes for
red and one blue so you see where's
where the pattern is you started off
equal but very quickly you become
unequal the rich get richer and the poor
get poorer and the versions of this the
chinese restaurant process is used to
model such sort of clustering effects
that's sort of the machine learning and
area and but here how does it work why
are we why do we why did I describe this
process one thing that happens with this
in the simple polio son process is that
lecture if I tell you there are 14 balls
in this urn I don't tell you the colors
turns out all these events are equally
likely which way they are rough split
that's the first observation and so the
way I want to think of it is that i am
running two separate poli irons on this
line and i have two urns let's say red
means i actually spread at Blue means I
stayed I didn't spread in that direction
and the two ones are going separately
and the adversary here Helen
it just knows the total length of the
spread so that means i don't know the
total number of red balls and the
findings author is tantamount to being
able to sort of separate the red balls
back into 11 and 12 so knowing which
ones came from which and because of this
uniform its being equally likely one can
calculate the probability the
likelihoods and their flat there as
opposed to the diffusion process which
had this central limit of concentration
and the direction probabilities
approximately one hour and there are
some constants involved to hear okay so
that's how you do it so you this is we
call this adaptive diffusion and just
not a very innovative name here and the
idea is that now when you spread you not
only send the packet but you also send
this control message the control message
says how far away you are and from the
original source and also how much time
it took to get there the point is just
like a velocity parameter if you wish
the faster I got the message from the
source either even faster I spread if I
got it slow for some reason then I get
even I make it even slower just like the
polio San process where the rich get
richer and the poor get poorer and so
this is the probability of spreading is
directly proportional to is actually
equal to the half distance and how far
we are from the source normalized by how
much time it took this is a very simple
discrete-time model okay so that's how
you keep doing this and so they can know
timing here so I just give you a length
and can you find it and one can plot it
and then now you get this full hiding
this is a very simple graph and it's
just a line and so you already see the
first train tuition yes yeah perfectly
so that was my next slide thank you
that's the Simon yeah we think about
that thank you so if there is one spy
somewhere and they got one the one of
the messages now it also got this
control information you know the
distance and the time when we got you
just hear the distance you don't even
you at the time that's it you're out of
luck right there totally I mean that's
exactly what's my next slide and so we
need to fix that but
we quickly realized that I do not need
to actually pass these parameters of
this process I only need to actually the
tosses give you a sample path sample all
the entire process ahead of time at the
source and only pass the sample path as
a long and now you can hide your so so
that's a pretty simple idea so this very
sensitive information the source always
gets located it's precisely what the
point was and I mean it the system idea
this is a system issue and the system
ways to solve it which is that you the
source already samples to get the entire
sample process one sample path of this
process and then you just pass the
process along and so it tells each node
how long it has to wait before it with
poor its spirits and each node can just
chop off its part so that it's it does
not even need it to the other points
alright so the control data is
independent the message author and the
one sample path tells you really nothing
about who the sources okay so and you
can plot so this time it's not as easy
so there's one more thing though if the
spy notes not only will there so control
message not very useful but spy notes do
not something more which is that they
know that times at which they got the
message so that's another thing though
these are not global times so the only
thing they don't know the winds that
clock started so it's relative and the
one can calculate the likelihoods again
it's a little bit messy so it's not a
simple formula anymore and but there is
a closed-form expression it's just not
very nice and you can definitely plot it
and the point I want to say is that the
detection probability is like 1 over N
as opposed to 1 over root okay so that's
the story and for just lines I mean
that's what as simple as setting as you
can get yeah this is the message came
through it does know that that it came
from somewhere in the middle so I put
down to spice because it's a line I mean
you can have more but you know it's
let's say it's in the send I assume that
the source in the middle is somewhere in
between the two spice let's say it could
have been on the left and right and you
could have missed it but I made it easy
if you have two spies which have
separation of k then it will be 1 over K
detection no detection by you be 1 over
K exactly so it's the length of the
spies spies are very close and you know
the source is
then that's exactly what it is and was
the distance between the spice but
there's timing so it's a sample path
dependent probability I mean there are
certain times when you can really know
it and but those times happen rarely so
it's okay so you can tie this on a tree
so maybe everything works out diffusion
doesn't because there is heavy
concentration I mean that's in fact
white bag the diffusion is particularly
bad you don't even have this one over
root and hiding inside with some
positive probability you get detected so
random spreading is just not a good idea
and turns out so let's try the this
polar zone process the chinese
restaurant process rich get richer
business i just try it turns out it's a
really bad too so and i just tried the
jordan center its again this
concentration so what's going on it
doesn't work at all and it's kind of a
bummer the point i guess is that because
they are going to a tree there's
exponentially in many paths and align
their only two paths and you could sort
of completely control the process the
tooth that's all that was happening
they're all equally likely but on a
graph as you go along there is
exponentially many parts and with high
probability there will be like a few
nodes which haven't waited at all they
really spread all the time and those
three nodes sort of is easy enough to
sort of triangulate the center loosely
that's what's happening and in practice
at least you can run some simple
centrality algorithm and you the source
gets detected it's just not a good idea
the point I guess is that I don't want
to let every path go along on a non
process I want to somehow control the
way in which things spread so one can do
that and in the interest of times I'll
just say that there is a way to sort of
again this is a system we show now so I
want to control the spread I don't want
let everything be in deprived every path
be independent across the exponential
path so I want to sort of have only
linear in the the time as many paths
going along and I can control that
that's for a later talk for a longer
talk okay and so if you plot the point I
guess is that if you try to calculate
the detection probability on a regular
tree it's quite nice in fact all nodes
are equally likely except what is
actually the center and
so that's sort of our main result i'm
going to talk like this I mean I've been
watching this workshop in person today
but also in swimming and there's always
a theorem and this is sort of our
theorem yeah so that's yeah I think
every talk at a theorem and i know this
is related topics but i should have one
theorem so one can do more general graph
so maybe the whole point is that we have
a messaging app and would like to work
on it i mean these regular trees don't
happen and they're all kinds of real
things first of all the recycles degrees
are could be very different some people
are you know lot of friends and there
are other people like me and their
boundary effects some people just don't
have anymore I mean that said they just
have one in friend and that's it they
don't have anyone else and there's
nothing else to spread so they're all
these boundary effects and the algorithm
sort of can get adapted around we don't
prove much about this but what I'll just
say that the likelihoods can be
approximated they cannot be found
exactly for a given graph but one can
approximate it quite well numerically so
and at least you know that the adversity
doesn't can't do much even if it did
something like a maximum likelihood
rules so we're working on this there are
many interesting issues I want to maybe
not just hide the sores I want to also
hide the realest we are interested in so
this is like a descent network people
are protesting and their authority and
governments around and yeah and so these
are what we want to think of these tools
as basic primitives to work in more
protest setting so systems are also
interesting i mean i would like to
really think of video sharing messaging
is fine and but video sharing is if you
follow the trend this is a very popular
thing live streaming of your life on
message incoming this is the most
popular app today and you know
distributed setting there are issues
like you know somebody went offline how
do you cash the message so all these
system issues one thing that is so this
talk was really about anonymity but one
thing i don't want to be anonymous at
all or the authors of this talk and this
work so yeah that is i want to publicize
loud and clear
so this joint work with all these people
I really enjoy so let's start with the
last say moon he's having fun and is
also a fun guy to work with he's my
colleague at Illinois Peter queiroz is
my graduate student has been working on
this project and Giulia font is a
student here and she's here and at
Berkeley and much of this work was done
when she was visiting us last summer and
thanks to conundrum chandran who's with
whom we've had several discussions on
this topic thank you can take a question
any questions I just want to say that
there is a paper Oregon archive and
cheetah toss some theorems and yeah
young some we go get on a software what
this river yeah what this does is to put
sort of an addict delay on top of that
so people have some social filter you're
right they whenever they want to press
like they press the like but on top of
it just put a delay that's proportional
to that you could say that exactly i
mean the idea is to sort of hide the
kill the timing the timing is usually a
killer in these four and six and we want
to mess with the timing yes Sharon
spices never okay good question they
could mess up but then you could do
nothing beyond so the way in all the way
we do it the spice we didn't really care
about what happened after the spice so
in other words they could mess up and we
don't know what happens afterwards so we
never so we can some sense we waited
until all the spice got what they got
and then they could call you it you're
right I don't know what might happen
afterwards so your effective n is
limited by the spy so I had a call to
nah mean I went fast but you can put a
call to the spice and they're like you
could say like a boundary and and you
want to hide as well as possible within
the garden thanks for moto